hi I'm Erik Bosse and let's talk about
this amazing but also at times
totally bewildering the first season of
the series Legion on FX now I know that
many of you have been asking for me to
go pick back up with these episode
breakdowns since I left off on episode 3
but I have finally returned to talk
about the rest of the season because
there's still so much to discuss
tons of miserable details and hidden
meaning and some mysteries that are
still kind of mystery so I'm going to do
my best to explain any confusion that
you still might have and just some cool
connections that I found and if you
haven't seen any of my Legion videos
before you really should go back to
watch my breakdown to the so it's one
two and three I go super in-depth in
those and a lot of my theories turn out
to be right some more wrong we won't
talk about those meanwhile since then I
did discover a few more connections in
those first three episodes that I'll get
to in this video and I really shouldn't
have to say it but boiler warning if you
haven't watched through the Legion
season finale episode 8 but if you have
watched that far you'll know that this
season did answer a lot of the big
questions that we had started in that
first episode most importantly the devil
with the yellow eyes it turns out is the
shadow king from the x-men comics now I
went a bit into his backstory in my
episode 2 breakdown but the shadow King
is Amahl Farouk one of the oldest and
most powerful mutants he's actually the
first evil mutant met by Charles Xavier
and he inspired him to create the x-men
the shadow king basically represents the
dark side of the human consciousness and
he was spawned by the very first
nightmare he feeds off of other psychic
mutants and possesses the bodies of
other humans he battled Charles Xavier
and later his son David Haller Legion
leading him in a coma
now in the show Legion Farouk is a
parasite that embedded himself inside
David's mind as a baby taking several
forms over the years of course there's
the devil with the yellow eyes but also
Lenny a very positive character a female
manifestation of the Shadow King that he
inserted into David's past memories to
replace a real man named Benny the
Shadow King also takes the form of this
creepy angriest boy in the world figure
as well as David's childhood dog king
whom we learned later in the season only
existed in David's mind Carey actually
realizes in episode 7 that the name King
is a reference to the shadow king the
dog in David's memories he disguised
himself every day
cute little beagle but the name King I
should I'm a Ferg and in my breakdowns I
pointed out a few of the show's clues
about the shadow king for example the
devil with the yellow eyes appears as a
toy in the opening seconds of the pilot
episode and Lenny is sneakily depicted
as a demonic presence haunting David in
a mirror also the devil with the yellow
eyes and the angriest boy where similar
clothes and they appear to be
interchangeable when they chase Sidney
and David through his memories in
episode 3 and Lennie suddenly transforms
into the devil with the yellow eyes more
than once and it turns out my paranoia
over scene eyes everywhere in episode 2
was justified those graffiti eyes that
showed up in frame when David and Lenny
were together later evolved into the
shadow Kings actual eyes as he watches
people inside the mental version of
clockworks but then upon rewatching
those first three episodes I noticed a
few more that I didn't point out and a
lot of it has to do with the color red
which I pointed out before as a colour
that the show used to suggest danger but
more specifically red is used to show
the Shadow King corruptive influence so
for example during that amazing
Bollywood dance number in the first
episode Lenny is shown wearing red
giggling devilishly as she dances by
herself
it's like she's operating all of these
other dancing mental patients like
puppets
hence me and how she will later control
the version of clockworks in David's
mind again dancing and celebration that
episode also in the opening images of
episode 3 King is seen repeatedly
fetching this red tennis ball later that
episode when King runs off in halloween
memory the dog transforms into the
terrifying angriest boy in the world
again the association with the color red
was an important clue there but let's
move on to chapter 4 an episode where
David meets Oliver Melanie's husband
played by the awesome Jemaine Clement
this episode is all about the power of
storytelling and it opens with this
great long Tag prologue from Oliver he
darts by quoting the German philosopher
Nietzsche in times of peace the warlike
man and
he's alluding to the inner struggle
David is fighting against the Shadow
King inside his mind Oliver then
explains the two types of stories that
we tell our children one's about fuzzy
little bunnies to teach empathy and
warnings to stay away from the ocean to
teach fear and then he makes this
promise and so I bring you tonight's
play the work in five acts about fuzzy
little bunny who got too close to the
bush and the episode that comes after
that delivers on that promise with
Sydney as the fuzzy bunny that we feel
empathy for but also serves as a
cautionary tale about the dangers of
curiosity which if you remember is
exactly the same theme from Oliver story
about the woodcutter in the crane and
then this story is broken down into five
acts Act one Sidney investigates dr.
Poole's office learning that David's
memories are unreliable and that he has
a history of violence Act two Amy
reveals that David never had a dog
suggesting that his condition goes back
at to a young age act three David meets
Oliver in the astral plane where we saw
the shadow king devil with the ellow
eyes as a dangerous monster haunting
David inside his own mind
Act four Sydney needs David's
ex-girlfriend who reveals that Lenny was
actually Benny in real life and that
leads them to dr. Poole's lighthouse
where in act 5 dr. Poole
different-colored I revealed him as the
I Walter who attacks them leading shadow
king Lenny to exploit the situation into
getting David to hand over control
Turner I'm also thinking it's a five
acts that all the references could refer
to the remaining five episodes of the
season four through eight with the first
three episodes kind of serving as a
prologue to David's story and then
Oliver not really interpreting the story
as beginning until he enters it it's
also interesting that Oliver brings up
this ocean imagery because that's a big
part of this episode it actually
connects to that question that Sydney
keeps asking which never really gets
firmly answered what did the star say
wanted to start a so Sydney here is
referring to the constellations that
David repeats during his session with
dr. Poole which he learned from
stargazing with his foster dad
it was cute
so Andromeda and Cassiopeia are
constellations named after figures from
Greek mythology now again this episode
is about storytelling so naturally it
references some of the most ancient and
famous stories in human history
Andromeda was known as the chained woman
her father and mother mothers named
Cassiopeia
chained her to rock by the sea to
appease a monster since Isis I tend to
destroy them she was later saved by the
hero Perseus and by the way this whole
Greek myth is part of Ovid's narrative
comb the metamorphosis which is the same
name of the jad song that Oliver plays
later this episode so all this sea
imagery serves as the cautionary part of
the tale the one that teaches fear go
too close to the ocean and you might
drown so of course where do sidney and
the others run into the greatest danger
the lighthouse by the sea so that to
answer city's questions is what the
stars say they tell these ancient
stories that teach us empathy and fear
and david repeats these constellation
names - dr. Poole as a way to tell
himself stories to distort his own
narrative hiding the truth about the
parasitic presence in his mind which is
trying to cover its tracks with these
new false memories also I like how David
name drops the constellations Canis
Major and lupus those are respectively
the dog and the wolf which are both
things that appear in this episodes the
dog king and the wolf which shows up as
this new taxidermy in Summerland some of
you also noticed this recurring image of
the chain the ladder that David climbs
into Oliver's lounge Plus David's
ex-girlfriends earrings and carried self
so other than yet another visual
reference to the chains of Andromeda all
these chains represent these symbolic
shackles that bind David he's constantly
weighed down by his own yellow-eyed ball
and chain and one other thing I liked in
this episode before I move on look at
the sign that the truck crashes into it
says uncertainty ahead so this is a fun
meta joke by the show David caused this
truck to swerve without realizing that
Sidney had swapped bodies with Walter
and that she was escaping
they're friends of course this was all a
trick by shadow king Lenny to get
influence over David and bring harm to
the rival influences over him Sidney and
the other mutants and that uncertainty
is what David really needed to be
cautious about too bad he missed a sign
okay moving on to Episode five and if
you notice david is acting differently
this episode it's because this isn't
David after waking up from its coma he
has allowed the Shadow King to take the
wheel
that's why David's creepy smile his
picks and gestures and his new
assertiveness all seem like Dan Stevens
is doing an impression of Aubrey Plaza's
Lenny and this episode drops a few
interesting clues one David changes his
shirt into this yellow triangle design
it kind of looks like an elevator up
call button as it's a devil with the
yellow eyes the Shadow King has taken
the elevator up to the surface of David
consciousness we actually see David and
Sidney taking an elevator together with
the transition opening up like elevator
doors into this mental hotel room that
David created for them to have sex in
but really all this aggressive behavior
stems from the shadow Kings control of
David in this episode another clue that
this place is too good to be true is the
bowl of strawberries that's covered in
bugs of course this is a red flag of the
shadow Kings actual toxic influence in
David's mind and notice how this shot
transitions to another red image the
bleeding gunshot wound on Kerry's
shoulder this is suggesting that this
seemingly perfect hotel room actually
has a bleeding festering wound from the
shadow Kings presence and notice how
when Sidney confesses to David the time
when she had sex with her mother's
boyfriend while swapped into her
mother's body David has this incredulous
look on his face because that's exactly
what the Shadow King is doing to him
right now
hopefully common variant his body to
have sex with someone else and as we've
seen before on the show this scene
transitions from blue lights the color
where David and Sidney teal stay
together to red light a place where
David is being threatened often by the
Shadow King in his mind and noted how
Lenny rhythmically pounds the ball
against the wall to bring him as cannon
fodder they're just going to slow us
down
foreshadowing the rhythmic tapping of
the ping pong ball and clock works at
the end of this episode now when they
catch up to this mess of bodies that
David left at Division three this music
is Radiohead's the Daily Mail it's
interpreted as the band's criticism
against the British tabloid the Daily
Mail where they believe the lunatics
have taken over the asylum and feed the
little guy to the hounds this of course
corresponds to David's situation where a
lunatic the Shadow King has taken over
the asylum in his head which literally
transforms into an asylum at the end of
this episode but of course all the
carnage wasn't done by David by The
Shadow King the security video showed
David prancing around the facility
similar to how Lenny would move and of
course we see the devil with the yellow
eyes and one of the monitors and then as
the old man in charge dies he utters
these terrifying final words it was too
late see I like how David called back
this line later in this episode hugging
on his face as he looks in the mirror
and now that we know David has a big
reason to be scared
the second song in this episode is
performed by David himself and Perri
creeped out the Rainbow Connection the
screamer
[Music]
so obviously this is a nod to Kermit the
Frog David even plays the banjo with his
legs up kind of similar to how prime it
looks but it's also a callback to the
Rolling Stone song she's a rainbow from
the first episode
[Music]
in both cases these songs about rainbows
suggest that a rainbow being an illusion
gives it a mysterious quality like it's
beautiful but it isn't actually real
similarly this pretty color shifting
reality that David has created in this
room is an illusion a cover for
something more sinister and when David
uses the words of the song to warrant
Sidney about what's on the other side of
the door she sees the dog king who
quickly transforms in the mirror to the
angriest voice since both of them are
the shadow king in different forms lenny
actually cycles through all these forms
again when messing with aiming I'm David
oh wait a Benny how do you mean
outlining you spread it King or is it my
favorite and all of this while David
convulses looking very similar to the
devil with the yellow eyes in Episode
two and this final sequence in David's
home sets the stage for everything we
see in the following two episodes as
Walter poses as Rudy and shoots at David
David to spend time by absorbing all of
them into his mind
fortunately David isn't in control of
that mind so as the devil yellow eyes
chases sit around the hotel room it
gradually grows from white to
increasingly red until they all find
themselves in this mental version of
clockworks where Lenny the Shadow King
is running the show and I like this
little detail of the ping-pong ball
sound playing over the final seconds in
the closing credits like the ticking
clock of clockworks
repeating over and over as they are
stuck inside this loop and that brings
us to the next episode chapter 6
Lenny questions each of David's
companions trying to weaken them and
notice the people she's most successful
like getting under their skin are
wearing red under their top layers first
Melanie feels guilty over her sad hope
about keeping Oliver and cryofreeze and
then putana me who saw his mother die
which happens while she's listening to
the song 99 lip saloon or in English 99
red balloon and then Walter who feels
insecurity over his status do I seem
like less than man tease meanwhile the
Carey's and Sidney are able to keep the
Shadow King out therefore no red and
notice how in this reality Amy
is recast as a strict nurse ratchet type
character that's because the Shadow King
is trying to turn all the people who
love David against them because as he
explains through Lenny later love is a
threat to his power and he probably
realized that this theme with autonomy
is a repeat of David's opening scene
with Lenny back in the first episode
except now the drooling patient is
replaced with Rudy who's paralyzed down
here because he's bleeding from a stab
wound on the surface another deviation
from the real-life plot worked in
episode 1 Sidney once he cherry pie this
time remember the real version of heard
claim to hate cherry pie I don't like
orange flavored things and I don't like
cherry censor things and another
callback Sidney now hallucinates bugs
infesting the pie just like the
strawberries in the previous episode so
like that place and David's mind this
place is also corrupted by the shadow
king and the reason only Sidney can see
these bugs as well as the door in the
hallway and why she feels that paranoia
that this clock works isn't real whereas
all the others accepted it's because of
her physiological connection with David
from when they swapped body she can
perceive the shadow king and only she
really knows what it feels like when
he's manipulating the reality now the
first of two amazing songs this episode
is a cover of Nina Simone's feeling
goodbye Bassnectar this whole sequence
is awesome kind of like the opening
titles in a Bond film lenny dances as
this red silhouette as the shadow king
celebrates his victory over taking
control of david kind of a call back to
that Bollywood number in the first
episode and throughout this we've seen
each of the invasive steps that the
shadow king took get brushed onto screen
as if this is part of David's painting
scoring drugs with David on seeing him
in the basement getting high together
appearing with him in the lab and
showing up in the kitchen during that
freakout and then notice this line from
Sidney yeah that feeling like
something's happened before of course
this whole scene is another repeat from
that first episode but reversed with
Sidney wearing the same pajamas that
David wore and David entering the room
in the same exact way that Sidney did
and while David acclimates
through this mind prison though is not
affected by the shadow Kings influence
Sydney and the Carey's dream about the
real world like
Sydney sees David's room with a gun fire
while male carry dreams about this I
personally dreamed of a very large ice
cube referring to the one in the astral
plane where Oliver lives also notice
what female carry brings up do you
remember that old movie 20,000 Leagues
Under the Sea like her male counterpart
she's also referring to Oliver whom
Linney referred to as Captain Nemo in
past episodes
Captain Nemo and his giant ice cube
Captain Nemo is the main character from
the book 20,000 Leagues Under the Sea
and Oliver walks around in an old-timey
diving suit which we learned later has
the same I introduced you to my friend
Jules Verne Jules Verne is of course the
author of 20,000 Leagues Under the Sea
and when Captain Nemo Oliver poles carry
into the astral plane I like how Carrie
greets him with several different
languages hello
good talk most of it konnichiwa caught
on on this guy this seems like a
callback to the first episode with all
those greetings on the wall and
different languages the other little
detail that I noticed was economy's
memory of his mother's death the way
he's shown under the table with his
grown self dressed as his childhood self
looks like a reference to the film
Eternal Sunshine of the spotless mind
and that film seems like a big
inspiration on this show and fatahna me
power in particular with characters
navigating around memories as if there
are physical places just like putana me
does and then the shadow king Lenny
reveals his parasitic nature and his
relationship to David's father Oh is
acting so holy and then gives away his
only son stop he pauses could hide you
from me but he was wrong I found you to
tweet Lou baby so not only is the shadow
king confirming the theory about Charles
with saber being his father he's
revealing that his goal is power to be a
god so it's interesting that he calls
David's father Charles Xavier
a man who acted so holy but then gave
away his only Son
that's a reference to God in the Bible a
holy figure who gave His only Son Jesus
to the world and as the enemy to that
God figure the shadow king Lenny is
casting himself as the devil probably
one with yellow eye and this whole
concept of the
a new powerful beam trying to take over
as God is expressed in this awesome song
that closes the episode oh you pretty
things
sung by lisa hannigan originally
recorded by david bowie I love this song
the lyrics are super deep and
philosophical Bowie's term of homo
superior is a reference to another
Nietzsche concept the ubermensch or it
has that fou plot so like you vermin I
don't have too good of a German accent
basically the superior man more evolved
human being who makes the
previous-generation redundant and does
away with them with his moral
superiority
so Bowie imagines this superior man as a
crack in the sky hand reaching down at
me
so they sample Bowie's song here to
reflect the Shadow King a superior
evolved mutant being threatening to do
away with the old order hoop and reaches
out at us through a crack in the sky
okay moving on to chapter 7 now the
whole point of this episode is to
explain in very effective visuals on a
blackboard through David's rational
British side using the Socratic method
on himself exactly what is going on so
really if you're confused I suggest to
rewatch this episode and since this
episode kind of does with itself it's
not a lot for me to explain but there
were a few fun details that I note for
starters I like how these opening images
basically say if this is your mind on
the shadow kicking and they depict that
deterioration in the form of clockwork
with the red light shining down the hall
red being the colour the shadow Kings
dangerous influence and then once its
eyes appear on the walls the building
begins to literally decay into a mess
and a riot this episode also makes a few
fun miserable references to Charles
Xavier
specifically the film version of the
character though I don't think we'll see
Patrick Stewart or even James McAvoy
appear on this show when Amy confesses
to shadow king Lenny about David's real
father we see this quick shot of
Professor X's wheelchair and then later
when David puts the pieces together
about his father's history with the
shadow king Dan Stevens actually does a
pretty great impression of Patrick
Stewart's sweetheart it's over I won it
means to me sugar does it British accent
I also like the choice in this episode
to you
these glasses inside clockworks to know
the difference between real threats and
mental projections and since so much
color represents so many different
things on the show it's nice to see
things in objective black-and-white at
first this whole black and white
aesthetic reminded me of the film
Rashomon
that's Akira Kurosawa's classic story
about objectivity and shifting
perspectives kind of like the
objectivity that Sydney and the others
are finally getting here but then later
after the shadow king Leni transformed
this into a silent film the loss of
everything also resembles the movie the
cabinet of dr. Caligari
that's a 1920 German expressionist
silent film about an insane hypnotist
who uses a sleepwalker to commit murder
that blood isn't that far off from the
shadow kings plot manipulating David for
similar violence he even keeps David in
this coffin like box like how the
hypnotist and that movie keeps his
sleepwalker in this wooden cabinet and
this is all part of my favorite sequence
in this episode one of my favorites in
the whole season largely because of the
music that Oliver is conducting here
this is Maurice Ravel's Bolero it's a
famous orchestral piece that has been
used and referenced all over the place
actually while filming Rashomon Akira
Kurosawa demanded his composure to make
a piece just like Ravel's Bolero
[Music]
Jeff russo whos the composer on Legion
said that his rendition of bolero which
he called folio merged the orchestral
elements with synthetic ones which you
can hear as the composition continues
I think that this reflects the
transition of the relative peace and
order that Oliver tries to bring into
the situation to the chaos and panic
that the shadow king unleashes and by
the way this feel that oliver attempts
to conjure with the song it's actually
composed of the letter from the word
shield and when the shadow king Lenny
does away with Walter the look of his
potty crumbling up is just super
unsettling his limbs contort
in a similar way to the guards bodies
look back in Division three and real
quick in case you were wondering how
exactly they get out of this mess Rudy
surprised as The Shadow King Lenny
restraining him at the same moment that
David is able to break his mind out of
captivity now that he understands his
mind better that frees the others right
as Carrie places that halo on David's
head in the astral plane isolating and
trapping the Shadow King and allowing
David to regain control over his psychic
superpowers to catch the bullet and yeah
this would seem like a fitting climax to
the season well if the Shadow King
hasn't been vanquished yet and the
government interrogator Clark has
returned which brings us finally to the
season finale chapter 8 the opening
images of this final episode are pretty
striking with these blinking color
squares similar to the closing credits
of every episode that same maddening
image that pops up right when you're
asking what is going on and listen to
this music the composer Russo said that
he rented an antique harpsichord from
the 1800 an instrument that he said he
didn't think it'd ever been used in TV
music before and as this montage follows
Clark's recovery after getting burned in
the first episode his appearance kind of
resembled to Batman villains different
superhero universe I know but his facial
scar tissue looks similar to two-face in
the Dark Knight and the way he demands
the mirror after the gods is removed is
very similar to Jack Nicholson's Joker
in the Batman movie
[Music]
err and when David confronts clerk he
says this lime wars over which she
wanted he's quoting John Lennon and Yoko
Ono here it's the chorus from their
Christmas song happy xmas war is over
which had a message of social unity and
an end to war so David is proposing a
similar peace between the mutants and
the human government forces who are
trying to kill them I also liked Clark's
reasoning in this episode that's a
problem because your babies and my
babies who wins that sandbox squabble
Clark is right to feel afraid for his
children his logic actually reflects the
message of boli's oh you pretty sings
song but rather than the mutants fearing
the shadow king as a destructive god
that needs to be contained Clark fears
David and the others as the same kind of
threat and notice how the shadow king
Lenny looks so decomposed this episode
with open wounds and pale skin melting
shoes and flies buzzing around kind of
like beetlejuice honestly that's because
this is Farooq at his weakest state
these rotting in his captivity inside
David's mind and I mentioned an earlier
breakdown how the music of Pink Floyd
was a huge influence on no Holly for
this whole show and I love how this
episode uses the opening composition
breathe from their landmark album Dark
Side of the Moon Rousseau referred to
this album as the sound of schizophrenia
the sound of mental illness in the 70s
and it's really the perfect music for
David seeing his life flashed before his
eyes as the shadow king is erased from
it and again this looks very similar to
Eternal Sunshine when Joel relives his
life moments when he tries to have his
ex-girlfriend deleted from its memory
and after the shadow king fights back
and threatens to kill David a man at war
with himself
Sydney saves him with this Sleeping
Beauty kiss swapping the demon into her
body who then uses their power to swap
in a carries body then Terry takes South
autonomy Melanie and Clark but David is
able to knock the Shadow King out of her
unfortunately this parasite finds a new
host another psychic with several layers
inside his mind Oliver and I love how
they let Jemaine Clement saying Tony
Bennett's if I rule the world is the
escape fun
with Oliver the shadow king is on its
way to rule the world
leni requests to go someplace warm
suggesting season two will change
locations from the Pacific Northwest
region to someplace further south we
will see and I don't know if you saw
this but like any good superhero
adaptation lebdon has a post credit
scene he gets sucked into this floating
drone or been taken away from Summerland
my guess is that this belongs to the
government forces like maybe it's the
equinox that they referred to earlier
certainly who knocks also if you look
closely you can see a woman wearing red
walking in the background of the scene
and she looks like the same mystery
woman that David saw a flashes of in
episode 2 and we never really got a
clear answer of who she is also another
mystery that the season never really got
to was the Red Hook incident that was
brought up in episode 1 after what I
have an in red Goku and say that's an
understatement so I'm wondering if this
woman is connected to Red Hook either
way I'm assuming that both of these
things will come up in season 2 okay I
am spent it is just good to hear those
are all the details that I found
interesting but I know I'm going to have
to rewatch these eight episodes a few
times the sort through it all and thanks
so much for your patience with this
Legion coverage like I really wanted to
do weekly episode breakdowns but I just
had too much of my plate with all the
other stuff that we cover on this
channel and if you don't already really
should check out some of it it's all
good stuff and let me know what you
think in a comment let's keep this
conversation going until the show comes
back like I could talk about this show
forever let's do it and if you really
like new rock stars you can contribute
to us on patreon thank you so much to
all of our current patrons especially
you pony stark you can hit me up on
Twitter a TA box with any thoughts you
have about Legion or if all the new rock
stars on Twitter at new rock stars for
updates on our videos alright thanks for
watching bye
you